hey folks welcome to the Darkhorse
podcast live stream I happen to know for
sure it's number 194 I also know for
sure that I am Dr Brett Weinstein you
are Dr Heather hying actually we know
nothing for sure how confident are you
of this um you know I suppose one could
tell a story in which none of these
things are true but assuming that any of
the things I think are true these things
are also true it's the 19 fourth live
stream of the Dark Horse podcast and uh
we are raring to go because um history
just refuses not to march on uh yes yes
life Marches On and uh as soon as it is
marched it becomes history I think it's
how that works is that how it works I
don't know I guess that would make sense
I'm going to think more about it and get
back to you and tell you whether I agree
yeah at which point uh this will be
history this will be history yeah all
right uh here we are on Rumble uh and
and elsewhere of course we're also on
YouTube and Spotify and apple podcast
and all of those places but um if you
have a choice if you're deciding between
those options please join us on Rumble
and also on locals where the watch party
is happening right now as we live stream
and um also on locals you can find our
uh monthly private Q&A which we did this
last Sunday we're going to be doing
another in couple weeks because of uh
upcoming
scheduling um anomalies and uh we also
have occasional impromptu amas on locals
we've got um access to the Discord
server soon if not already uh I I don't
know yet uh what what is happening with
that it's supposed to be happening um
but the Discord server brings us a
question every week for our Q&A that
happens after our live streams uh which
we will be doing today and uh lots of
other great stuff so please consider
joining us there okay we're going to be
talking about um a number of things uh
in um mRNA space and Pharma space today
yeah sounds like fun yeah um uh in part
um prompted by uh the announcement of
the Nobel in physiology and medicine and
in part prompted by my uh research this
week into um a drug uh that reports to
be excellent in preventing
cardiovascular um uh
illness uh and uh that will dive into um
into phal land uh which I also published
on Natural Selections this week so I
encourage you to go there we'll also be
talking about it um but yeah without
further ado
what does that even mean without further
I know that you can have a lot of a do
and sometimes it isn't about anything
it's you know language is weird and
there are just some words that you only
use in the context of a phrase and if
you try to pull them out uh they they
are glaringly obvious as not actually
being Standalone Words which makes them
maybe not words all when was the last
time you went traing without
gallivanting
right yeah yeah no I have I have I think
I have never right and when is the last
time you encountered flum without Jetsam
I mean well no I mean those those those
exist they all exist but no I'm not sure
they do I mean you actually have been
the one to uh point out the precise
different and different definitions of
flum and jsum those actually exist as uh
distinct entities so I I don't think
example I have been pointing that out
for a long time but apparently I had the
definitions wrong which our friend Brad
corrected me on so uh I'm now up to date
on these things but yes so please you
just keep on going back
what are you going to do you know I mean
as you point out history is history and
there's not a whole lot we can do about
it yes but you
okay okay so we have three sponsors this
week as usual uh there is there is yours
uh and uh we are going to read these ads
now uh at the top of the hour seed
uncruise and mind Bloom are our
excellent sponsors this week as always
uh we choose only sponsors uh for whom
we actually um have affinity and these
are those our first sponsor this week is
seed a probiotic that really works if
you've tried probiotics before and got
nothing out of it try seed it's designed
differently from other probiotics it's
designed better it actually works seed
helps improve the health of your gut
microbiome which means that it supports
you becoming healthier overall our
resident gut microbes directly impact
the development and function of the
immune system even before we're born
microbes inform our immune system
teaching our body how to distinguish
between benign substances and pathogenic
antigens that is substances that our
body doesn't recognize as its own you
can support your gut immune axis in a
variety of ways including by
prioritizing sleep new research suggests
that the gut microbiome has its own
circadian clock and that changes to your
normal rhythms can disrupt your microbes
and the important functions that they
perform prioritizing regular sleep can
thus help get your gut immune access
healthy seeds DS1 daily synbiotic also
supports your gut immune access seed is
a plant-based Prebiotic and probiotic
with 24 strains have been clinically or
scientifically studied for their
benefits six 16 of those 24 strains are
specifically geared towards digestive
health and four of the 24 probiotic
strains are known to promote healthy
skin your skin like your gut has its own
microbiome seed supports both gut and
skin
Health seed is free from 14 major
classes of allergens including but not
limited to sugar animal products soy
gluten peanut glyphosate Dairy shellfish
and corn and seed is basically double
hauled with its capsule in capsule
design it is engineered to maintain
viability through digestive tract until
it reaches your colon where you want it
and the same design makes it resistant
to oxygen moisture and heat meaning that
a refrigeration is necessary so you can
travel with it seeds daily symbiotic
supports gut skin and heart health and
micronutrient synthesis we have heard
from several people who have used seed
and Report improvements of their
digestive function in 24 to 48 hours so
start a new healthy habit today visit
seed.com Darkhorse and use code
Darkhorse to redeem 25% off your first
month of seeds ds01 daily symbiotic
that's seed.com Darkhorse and use code
Darkhorse at checkout now when you say
uh our resident microbes it sort of
sounds like microbes that are here
living in Residence with the podcast and
that's not what you mean you're talking
about you figure we have some I mean I
guess we do but they're not official I
mean I haven't named them right well for
one thing there are bound to be a lot of
them so I mean I think that's true in
the gut as well yes that is part of the
point here that is the point here all
right well I'm glad we cleared that up
just in case anyone well I'm glad we'
muddled that up what I'm really glad
about I believe that you are you've
known me a long time our second sponsor
this week is unru small ship Adventures
UNC Cru explores by sea and by land they
have boats that hold orders of magnitude
fewer people than most cruise boats and
they take their passengers to some of
the world's most magnificent places
Panama Costa Rica Galapagos the Sea of
Cortez and Mexico Alaska even our own
backyard the San Islands when un crw
first approached us we were skep iCal
our standards for travel and especially
anything bordering on adventure travel
are high we have years of experience
leading trips to the scabs of Eastern
Washington the Clum River Gorge as well
as the andian paramal Galapagos and the
Amazon we know that most trips do not
meet expectations un Cruise in contrast
exceeds expectations the small boats of
uncruise allow passengers to get real
deep experience their largest boat can
accommodate a mere 86 guests the boats
of on crws take small groups of people
to places that larger boats can't go and
the excursions are designed to bring
people into deep nature with without
destroying it when we spoke with CEO Dan
Blanchard we discovered a shared ethos
the value of wild roadless nature of
exploration and of observation we took
an uncr week-long trip to the Inland
Waters of Southeast Alaska in early May
of this year and we Blown Away by what
we saw and what we were able to do we
saw sea otters with their pups mountain
goats Eagles in their nests brown and
black bears puffins orcas humpbacks
Arctic turns too many species to list
really and mile after mile of the most
breathtaking scenery each day we got off
the boat to hike or kayak and the crew
and naturalist guides were to a person
kind knowledgeable and enthusiastic the
food was surprisingly good as well and
food preferences and sensitivities were
handled perfectly and every sailing with
UNC cruise is all inclusive
Transportation drinks Farm totable
Cuisine daily excursions everything is
included un Cruise understands that the
boat is just a tool their small ship
cruises take guests through communities
and locals on the ground so that they
the guests can have actual experiences
UNCW unru is giving Darkhorse listeners
a fantastic deal $500 off their current
cruises an offer that you can combine
with other offers as well so start
thinking about winter in the tropics now
or spring trips in Alaska plan a trip
with uncruise today and take advantage
of our great offer go now to UNC
cruise.com Pages Darkhorse remember to
save $500 on your trip go now to
uncruise Darkhorse once more that's
uncruise
docomo you won't regret it as you know
when we were on our cruise I spent a lot
of time making these little video post
cards where I would just hold the phone
perfectly still as the ship moved and uh
some beautiful unnamed piece of
wilderness passed in front of us and I
find myself going back to those things a
lot because it was really so Majestic so
I've never heard you call them video
postcards before but it sounds from your
description just now that there were
postcards that you sent to
yourself that is uh strange and a little
awkward but yeah I guess I guess that's
how it turned out since I haven't sent
them to anybody else but that was not
the intent when I made them um all right
uh our final sponsor this week is mind
Bloom mind Bloom is the leader in inhome
ketamine therapy offering a combination
of scientifically robust medicine with
clinically guided support for people
looking to improve their mental health
and well-being if you or someone you
love is struggling with mental health
issues those issues May Loom large in
your life there is no one-size fits-all
solution but you know that you and your
loved one needs something that will help
you achieve a real and Lasting
breakthrough maybe it's time for you to
consider a guided ketamine Therapy
Program from mind Bloom mind Bloom could
be your next and most successful chapter
in improving your mental health and
well-being mind Bloom connects patients
to licensed psychiatric clinicians to
help them achieve better outcomes with
lower costs greater convenience and an
artfully crafted experience to begin
take mind Bloom's online assessment and
schedule a video consult with a licensed
clinician to determine if mind Bloom is
right for you if approved you'll discuss
your health history and goals for mental
health with your clinician to tailor
your mind bloom regimen mind Bloom will
send you a kit in the mail complete with
medicine treatment materials and tips
for getting the most out of your
experience after only four sessions 89%
of Mind Bloom clients reported
improvements in their symptoms of
depression and anxiety reports one
client on their site mind Bloom has
enabled me to release the hold of
negative thought patterns in my life
mind Bloom has guided so many people
into a better chapter of mental health
and well-being right now mind Bloom is
offering our listeners $100 off your
first six session program when you sign
up at mind bloom.com Darkhorse and use
the promo code Darkhorse at checkout go
to mind bloom.com Darkhorse promo code
Darkhorse for $100 off your first six
session program today that's mind Bloom
m i n d b l o o
m.com Darkhorse promo code
Darkhorse and um we've also I failed to
mention in the runup to this we've also
got uh a new look to our store a new
look to our store indeed yeah uh so
we've got all the cool stuff that you
have come to expect uh with designs
including um Darkhorse welcome to
complex systems do not affirm do not
comply first against the wall Club epic
Tabby all of this plus one that's new to
us here new and it's really a symbol of
a much bigger project we are going into
the pizza business now the reason that
we are going into the pizza business is
that we noticed a little something um
during uh the past Wave of mask mandates
what we noticed was that for many of us
uh who came to understand that masks
were not an effective way of controlling
the spread of the virus um that there
was I wouldn't call it a loophole but
there was an opportunity that you didn't
have to wear your mask while you were
eating which means that for those of us
who don't think that the masks are an
effective uh controller of the virus's
spread we could just simply eat all the
time but the problem with that plan is
that it will make you very very fat and
so then put you at greater risk for
illness exactly it puts you at greater
risk for the virus in question so oh
that was probably fat phobic on my part
uh no doubt not apologize um if it was
fat phobic then it's inherently
hydrophilic I believe so that's good I
think um unless you're trying to dry off
but I digress the point is the solution
to the problem of eating we want this
still up don't we yeah of course we want
it still up the solution to the problem
of how is it that you can eat thereby
not having to wear your mask but not
grow incredibly fat the solution is
Jake's micro pizza now I have Jake's
micro Pizza Jake's micro Pizza which I
must say is fantastic and the slices are
so small they are zero calorie and we
have literally not found the threshold
where you have eaten enough slices to
amount to any amount of calories so
sounds like a Buckminster Fuller sort of
universe it it is these have been
and we Harvest them humanely we produce
the best pizza you're ever going to have
in such tiny slices that you can afford
to just keep eating them point of order
yes name a pizza ingredient that grows
on a tree
uh I knew you were going to call me out
on that and I will come up with one um
it's not a
tree yeah I don't you're really looking
for a tree a you went there wait a sec I
can't pineapples no Tomatoes no milk no
wheat not a tree uh wait a second I got
it oh do you I got it mhm um arugula
nope ah wait there is there is here in
the San Juans a bakery that makes the
most amazing pizza and on Fridays they
have a specialty pizza arugula and lemon
yeah and the lemon on the on a tree
perfect how many of you have actually
had lemon on a pizza
it's I have to correct I I believe that
I saved you here well but you've also um
aired you have aired significantly you
have emboldened our competitors saying
they make the most amazing Pizza no no
we make the most amazing pizza at Jake's
micro pizza now that wasn't I I did not
mean for that to be a superlative right
exactly they make a very acceptable
Pizza not as good as Jake's I mean in
fact they make an excellent pizza it's
just not quite as good as Jake's now I
will point out right for those of you
who are sticklers for the truth Jake
does not exist Jake is I was just going
to ask about his origin story well I'm
going to tell you it's rather a lot like
Mr Zingerman's origin story and let us
hope that the fate of Jake's micro Pizza
is like that of the Zingerman's
operation for the few people in our
audience who aren't familiar with Ann
Arbor Michigan uh you might want to
explain that well zingerman is now world
famous Welling will Jake's micro Pizza
be but that doesn't mean that everyone
knows that he doesn't exist zingerman is
a very lovely and I will say decided ly
expensive Deli in uh in Ann Arbor
Michigan so good it's really good they
have incredible sandwiches made to order
Tom's new job is a fine sandwich a uh
variation on the the Georgia Ruben which
is a local favorite in in Michigan but
anyway um I want to interject something
that I believe you guys forgot which is
the new store can be found at Darkhorse
store.org darkh hor store.org is where
you too can get your uh your uh
merchandise advertising that you are a
fan of Jake's micro pizza and perhaps
are eating it right now right now Jake's
micro Pizza may or may not be available
in your neighborhood yet we are
expanding very rapidly but the shirts
are available the storefronts also micro
uh these are it's delivered by it's it's
a truck-based service there's no address
to Jake's micro pizza but it is micro as
well no that is illegal um so no we are
a buy the book operation we delivering
uh Jake's micro Pizza produced in a
sanitary facility mobile but a sanitary
facility it's it's just good stuff has
there been processing of wheat or soy or
peanuts or anything in that facility or
is it uh our trucks literally avoid
roads on which there are facilities that
process either nuts or wheat so it's
really but nut soy no we don't care
deeply about that um no um but but nut
and wheat nut nuts and wheat s mhm um
right but in any case uh check to see
whether Jake's micro Pizza is available
in your town but get your shirt now just
so that you're ready at the point so at
the point that you are told to mask up
you can uh start ebly argue that you are
in fact uh eating Jake's micro Pizza
increasingly uh well known and available
soon from a truck near you yes from a
pizza delivery truck near you and uh
given that you are eating you don't need
a mask up no no you can mask when you're
done eating Jake's micro pizza that's
that's the idea all right
excellent all right and what was the URL
on that again that's a Darkhorse store
Darkhorse store.org is where you can get
that and uh all all the rest of the good
stuff
yeah okay um where do we want to
start maybe we should start with the uh
the news of the Nobel Prize announcement
and the various Associated questions
issues okay all right so the Nobel Prize
in physiology and medicine was announced
not yesterday but the day before and the
winners I hope not to mispronounce her
name but one of the winners is Cataline
kerico I believe is the way to pronounce
it and her uh fellow laurate is Drew
Weissman uh both from the University of
Pennsylvania and they were awarded uh
the prize
for um the
modification of the nucle sides that are
involved in the mrnas that facilitated
the production of the current crop of um
mRNA so-called vaccines now on the one
hand it is
interesting that this prize was awarded
to these two people for the thing that
it was explicitly awarded for so for
those who are aware of the back story
there has been a lot of debate about who
is responsible for the technology
underlying the MRNA vaccines uh our good
friend alexandros marinos has done a
deep dive on this topic and he has
vetted um Robert Malone's claim to be
the inventor and it turns out that
Robert Malone is the inventor and that
is not a subjective claim it's not as if
there were not other people involved in
the work and it is not as if other
people have not added things to it but
the fundamental underlying technology is
technology on which uh Robert Malone
sought and uh was granted patents and he
has the publication so Robert Malone is
the inventor of this technology um and
they did not give the Nobel Prize for
the MRNA technology in these vaccines I
think it's fairly clear that because
they gave it for a much narrower
Discovery um that they explicitly say
facilitated the production of the
vaccines it seems a tacit
acknowledgment that Malone is the
inventor they did not wish to empower
him because his critiques of the way
these vaccines were
deployed and manufactured have been so
devastating that they preferred instead
to give it to two people who yes did
some important work but no we're not the
inventors of the fundamental technology
so that is an interesting tacit
acknowledgement um if a uh strange turn
of historical events in
science now I want to drill down though
on what they did give the award for and
what its implications are and then I
want to look at a couple of pieces of uh
video in which first the committee that
awarded this Nobel Prize speaks about
its beliefs and then another earlier
video from long before the prize was
awarded actually in January of 21 um in
which one of these now Nobel laurates
speaks about his invention he speak
which at that point was just brand new
being Unleashed on the world and uh and
people um had a few questions right okay
so the the thing for which the uh Nobel
Prize was awarded was the
modification of the nucleo sdes in the
MRNA so just a little bit of biology um
mRNA inv in involves four uh distinct
nucleo sdes and um those nucleo sdes are
uh a component of all of the mrnas in
your cells and the ordering of them
contains information that then instructs
a ribosome another component of your
cell which is actually made of RNA to
produce protein and protein is the
Workhorse of biology protein are the
little machines that do stuff um it is
it is the product so your DNA produces a
message in RNA that's mRNA messenger RNA
which then becomes is uh translated into
protein and those proteins are doing the
work the proteins are the Target and the
way these vaccines work is they insert
an mRNA message that describes a
particular protein that your cells do
not normally make and it effectively
tricks your cells
into producing that protein the idea
being that your immune system will then
see these foreign proteins learn to
react to them and then when the virus
that also carries these proteins arrives
your immune system is alerted in advance
and it goes after it and shuts down the
virus before it gets a chance to make
you sick or to move to anyone else
that's that's the basic
outline the nucleoside Innovation for
which the Nobel Prize here was given was
the conversion of the uracil that is the
natural nucleotide in mRNA to something
called pseudo urine now pseudo urine is
something that is chemically
sufficiently similar that it fits in an
mRNA chain the same way that a urasil
would and it allows the translation by
the
ribosome to occur but what it does is it
interrupts the body's natural tendency
to break down the mrnas so imagine that
your body produces a lot of mrnas that
produce proteins but those mrnas are
constantly being taken apart and so the
way the body regulates whether or not
you're producing proteins or not is
whether it introduces new mrnas the old
ones having been broken down so by
introducing so I the the weird caveat
here is that pseudo urine is actually
something that nature does occasionally
introduce into mrnas but it does it very
sparsely that is to say if nature
decides that a particular MRNA would be
better off in a more stable form it may
introduce a pseudo urine but it doesn't
do it across every uracil in the message
so what these folks have done is they
have introduced a whole slew of pseudo
urines making the MRNA transcript
extremely durable just question uh you
said a whole slew so um not all the OS
are okay that's what I thought now
there's also question about um
manufacturing and technique and how
effective but the intention is all it's
not you know a whole slew sounds like
there's a lot more than one but um but
the if if it's uril is replaced with
pseudo iDine that's a different kind of
situation right now um a couple of uh
interesting points one Let's uh give
them the benefit of the doubt and by
them I do not only mean uh these now
Nobel laurates but um those in involved
in the program to produce these vaccines
who did not initially know whether or
not they would be successful at
producing enough protein to induce an
immune
response they might have thought well
one of the challenges is that the MRNA
is going to be rapidly broken down and
that that may mean that even though we
have introduced something that might
technically be able to produce an immune
response it won't be around long enough
to succeed at it so they may have turned
up the dial on stabilizing the MRNA
thinking that that was necessary to get
any effect at
all that said what they did was
absolutely Reckless especially in an
environment in which the testing was
extremely
truncated
so
they've they've stabilized the mrnas to
a degree that they cannot say in advance
they've done it in a way that is most
unnatural and now they've been given a
prize
for um that stabilization which the
Nobel Committee in awarding the prize
says was essential to producing a viable
vaccine now that's not true and I would
ask people to go look at Chris
martinson's analysis of this but Chris
Martinson points out that there are
versions of the vaccine even mRNA based
versions of the vaccine that were not
pseudo iDine stabilized and were
initially tested and did produce an anti
a detectable antibody resp response
which means that the choice to do this
was not inherently necessary it's
possible that a version of the vaccines
which had not been pseudo urine
stabilized might have worked but we
never got a chance to find
out all
right so with that as background I now
want to look at these two pieces of
video the first one from the Nobel
committee itself which held a miniature
press conference and the first thing
you're going to hear is a Chinese
journalist in eng English asking a
question about the long-term safety of
these vaccines and then you will hear uh
the answer as delivered by by the
committee go ahead and show
that uh hello this is Ty media from
China and with the MRNA we don't know
the long-term effect yet so do you have
any concern over
that uh Rickard would you like to
respond to that that
question yes um of course you know M
vaccines have only been given for a
certain amount of time which begs your
question having said that of course the
MRNA vaccine that is given is very
transient and the fact that 13 billion
people have gotten the virus vaccine
virus and uh I mean that and the amount
of side effects noted to date is
extremely limited so uh I don't think
think it's a it's a major
concern anyone else want to add to that
or that's fine I guess I think
that's that well it can't be integrated
into the nucleus into the DNA and that's
you know a safety precaution the adverse
effects that's been noted is mostly a
mild my carditis or perimyocarditis
mainly affecting young men faes but that
normally resolves without any long-term
effect okay
now I find this piece of video shocking
because it nobody who is familiar with
the
actual vaccine technology and the
evidence that has emerged could possibly
deliver this answer in good faith this
answer is too far from reality to be
believed and yet these people appear
Earnest in delivering it they do not
appear to be knowingly lying and yet
they essentially have to be now notice
that the first thing that the person
identified as Rickard says is that we
don't have to worry about the long-term
Hazard of the MRNA vaccine
because their presence is
transient now notice this exact
committee has just given the most
coveted scientific prize there is for
specifically the innovation of making
the MRNA less transient precisely they
have given it for this thing and yet he
says transient as if he is not just
calling into question the wisd of this
committee that has awarded uh a prize
for making it less transient now how not
transient is it let's talk about
specifically the mrnas the answer is we
don't know how not transient it is what
we do know is that it has been found two
months after inoculation it's not that
it stopped being findable after two
months we stopped looking after two
months we know that it persists for two
months and then how long after that we
cannot say that is anything but
transient it is um pratal does not begin
to describe the way this mRNA behaves in
fact when I spoke to Robert Malone about
it I used the analogy that this was like
a fiberglass log in a zoo exhibit right
it looks like a log but it's not being
broken down by termites and fungi
because it's made of fiberglass this is
a permanent feature of the environment
but it's it's even it's it's even worse
even worse than right um as as you well
know which is that it's not it's not
just a static permanent feature of uh
you know we don't know permanent but
it's not just a static very longlived
feature of your body now it is a factory
uh it it it has the instructions to make
the in this case the spike protein um
and so presumably will continue to do so
so long as it exists um so it's not just
uh floating about um ready to be uh
disassembled by your immune system as uh
the effects the the product of a normal
vaccine of a traditional vaccine would
be um it is a factory for the production
of the antigen that you are trying to
get immune response for against um that
is itself been stabilized so that it can
attain a less transient State yep okay
uh Rickard also says that the side
effects to date are
limited um what actually the side
effects the severe ones are off the
charts in every place that we have
monitored now the only place that you
can claim that that's not true are
places where we haven't looked but in
the VS System the yellow card system the
military system we see an off the charts
adverse event signal what's more when
this has been looked at carefully in a
scientifically rigorous way we have seen
evidence of an off-the-chart signal even
in the clinical trial data so there's a
paper which uh we will um link to the
description of this video um first first
off author is uh Joe framan Peter Doshi
is the last author that looked at the
clinical trials and found something like
a 1 in
800 incidents of a severe
adverse
effect so that is not a minor level and
what's
more that measurement 1 in 800 severe
adverse reactions in the clinical trials
is the tip of the iceberg inherently
because it was measured over such a
short period of time that is to say
anything that happened months down the
road from vaccination was not captured
in that in fact fizer's data only goes
one month so in one month they saw a 1
in8 100 level of severe Adverse Events
that's not rare and we are not talking
about Minor Adverse Events
either um and then the next gentleman
says that mostly what we see is
myocarditis he is for some reason he
says well but that's mostly uh in young
males I don't know why anybody is
supposed to be comforted by that um but
he says mostly myocarditis mostly in uh
young males and mostly it resolves
without any long-term effect which is
nonsense myocarditis is an inherently
serious condition we see a very powerful
signal that looks strongly associated
with vaccinations uh with these
vaccinations uh of uh all cause
mortality that does not begin with the
onset of coid but does begin with the
onset of the vaccination campaign so
there's every reason to think that this
isn't true that it's not limited um to
myocarditis and that the rate is very
high and serious and some of these
things are uh life shortening in fact um
one of the things I wanted to talk about
a little bit later but we I think we can
go there now um is is this published in
nature uh this last week coid vaccines
linked to unexpected vaginal bleeding a
large cohort study measured how
frequently women reported bleeding after
receiving Co 19 Jabs and uh I was going
to bring this up on the last show
because this is relevant to um to the
lambasting of Naomi w by the mainstream
media including by Naomi Klein and her
new book doble ganger um because wolf
was one of the people who was saying
this over and over and over again and
got you know roundly mocked and
demonetized and deplatformed and all of
these things um for for saying this and
of course now that it's n in nature I
guess we're allowed to talk about it um
but but oh no did I have my screen back
thank you um now that it's in nature
we're allowed to talk talk about it but
there are um we are being assured
nevertheless uh that they are safe and
effective and um the link in the peace
in nature as to their safety and
Effectiveness uh is
to uh this article which you can now
show Zach um from February
2021 their evidence in a in an article
published now from a cohort study now
demonstrating that actually the people
like Naomi wolf who were yelling from
the rooftops about um menstrual effects
in women who were getting these shots uh
our Assurance is that these are safe and
effective goes back to February 2021 Co
vaccines and safety what the research
says and if I may uh have this back
thank you uh so I can go to my version
of this hold on um yeah I don't have
anything um you can you can show my
screen again if if you want um So Co
vaccines and safety what the research
says as the vaccines are rolled out
researchers learning about the extent
and nature of side effects uh they
assure us um that it's it's basically
fine again this is proof now that these
vaccines are safe and effective from
February 2021 but even so they
acknowledge um that there are side
effects I got the vaccine 6 hours later
I had chills and high fever muscle aches
I went to bed for 24 hours
um these uh yeah so you had you thing to
say here yeah I was going to say that
this you know in the
um the the large quiver of tricks that
Pharma plays this idea of looking way
back into the early days in order to
figure out whether something is safe and
effective is uh clearly used again and
again and it's used in fact in the
trials themselves so so one of the
things that happens is in these trials
there is an ethical requirement that if
a drug is so good it is it is
demonstrated to be so good in the
process of the clinical trial that it
would be unethical not to give it to
everybody then you unblind the trial
effectively ending it making it
impossible to find long-term effects so
T Pharma Targets this and in fact if you
couple this with what we've covered here
before the Norman Fenton and Martin uh
mcneel yeah um
uh piece the so-called Cheap Trick where
they create the impression of efficacy
by using a cut off date of two weeks and
they classify everybody who gets um sick
in those two weeks as unvaccinated
thereby generating I think it was 83
plus% impression of efficacy just simply
through um shifting categories having
nothing to do with the effect of the
drug in question so fent mcdel just to
remind everyone are uncovering the stati
itical trick uh by which anything could
be demonstrated could be demonstrated in
quotes uh to be effective simply by
categorizing things in the way uh that
these results have been categorized y um
I am experiencing a bit of Terror it's
McNeil not Neil did I did I mess it up
have I added a syllable to his name in
any way in any case let's maybe you
could figure that out um but let's
continue what we've yeah go ahead yeah
so um
in the middle of talking about um the
the awarding of the Nobel and Physiology
and Medicine uh to the two people who
have invented I I think rather than
discovered in this case um and of course
the award could be given for either
invention or Discovery um but the
invention of a way to make less
transient and more stable uh the MRNA
that is used in the MRNA platform um
that is being given in these so-called
vaccines um we are talking about we are
you know seeing the committee saying oh
the effects um any side effects are
going to be transient because the
vaccines themselves are transient when
in fact the award has been given
precisely um for the for the trick for
the for the scientific trick the
impressive um if not necessarily um safe
scientific trick of making um of
replacing Oso with pseudo Idan and thus
making the entire object uh more likely
to stick around in the body um we see
new evidence of uh of even nature saying
ah there's workout now that says yeah
all those women who were saying they
were experiencing uh weird menstrual
effects were actually right but nothing
to see here folks they're still safe and
effective here check out this thing that
we wrote back in February 2021 and just
one more Link in that chain before we go
back to um uh the Nobel story as long as
we're digging deep in the nature
archives which we didn't want to do it
was nature that is exciting their own AR
archives pretty deep from two and a half
years ago as evidence that these
vaccines are safe and effective they
have in that same safe and effective
article from February 2021 a related
article
called um how coid unlocked the power of
RNA and this is from January 2021 so we
are going way back in time right this is
remember the the first people were
getting their vaccinations and this was
mostly uh medical providers in Janu in
December 2020 so in January 2020 one
there are not that many people who have
at that point many people are clamoring
for these things that people are trying
to get vaccinated but they're just it's
the roll out is is careful uh I mean
it's fast but um what we are told is
there's not enough right and this of
course increases demand uh because
people want something that's ins shorted
Supply um but in the middle of that we
have how Co unlocked the power of RNA
published in nature January 2021 let me
just read a couple of sections from this
from this article 5 years and one Global
pandemic later RNA vaccines are proving
their worth last month two RNA vaccine
candidates one from us pharmaceutical
Giant fiser and bio entech in Mains
Germany and another from madna in
Cambridge Massachusetts one emergency
approval from Regulators in several
countries to fight coid 19 remember when
that was new right so go down in this
article a little bit more side effects
can be troubling the RNA technology has
proved itself but it's not done yet says
Philip dormitzer head of viral vaccines
research at 5 and a former colleague of
Gils at novares and now that we've seen
it work for Co 19 it's tempting to want
to do more and I think I have one more
little section stability and safety
despite its many potential advantages
today's RNA vaccine technology leaves
room for improvement this technology is
still super early says Robin shatak an
immunologist in Imperial College London
and we're going to see multiple
generations and iterations over the
coming years I
suspect and then we have um three
examples of um the problems the
potential problems with this uh vaccine
again um first there's the issue of Cold
Storage there's another challenge so far
RNA vaccines tested for human use
against disease coid 19 or otherwise
have generally required a double dose to
be effective and judging by poor
compliance with other multi-dose
vaccines many people who get the first
shot probably won't get the second well
that didn't turn out to be the case by
and large although some people stopped
at one new Delivery Systems could fix
that at vacs Technologies in Cambridge
Massachusetts for example research have
developed a wearable skin patch studed
with tiny silk tip dissolvable micro
needles that slowly trickle vaccine into
the body wow and finally administering
the vaccine in drips instead of all at
once could help to solve a third
drawback side effects severe reactions
although transient do seem to be more
common with Co 19 shots than with other
immunizations more than 80% of people
who receive the Mna vaccine and clinical
trials had some type of systemic
reaction to the shot with bouts of
fatigue muscle pain and other issues
that often prove proved briefly
debilitating I share that to remind us
and to alert those who weren't aware
that back in January of 2021 even nature
was pointing out that one of the
problems with these plat with this
platform that the entire world is being
encouraged nay in some cases mandated to
get was severe side effects side effects
so much more widespread and also severe
in individuals than other vaccines had
that it was worth mentioning as a
possible reason that maybe this wasn't
such a good idea after all well but
they're allowed to say stuff like that
we are Heretics if we say things like
that right so you know you have to check
your privilege and by doing that that
means you got to check which privileges
you are allowed based on your position
in the universe right all right so I
wanted to cover one more thing from that
video before we move on to the next one
okay um he makes the claim the second
speaker makes the claim that the MRNA is
is not integrated into the nuclear DNA
and therefore that is another reason um
to uh imagine that long-term effects are
not a problem now this may technically
be right but it ought to be no Comfort
based on what we Now understand and mind
you this is a modern video so he has
every reason to understand everything
that you and I
understand whether or not the message in
the MRNA Finds Its way into the nucleus
and is ever integrated into the nuclear
Genome of your cell
something else does appear to be making
its way into the nucleus from these
vaccines and this is a mindblowing story
which we have yet to cover in detail but
this is largely the work of Kevin
mckernan and an anonymous account jigy
leaks um on Twitter and I would say um
it is clear that mckernin has Unearthed
a tremendous amount of DNA contamination
in the vials this is is work done where
somebody one of the people who was
involved in the vaccination campaign
saved every vial and that left a
residual that could be tested for its
content so this is a fairly large sample
of vials and what what mckernan
Unearthed was a huge amount of DNA
contamination what the hell is DNA doing
in there at all and the story behind
this is mind-blowing and it will have a
a resonance to something that uh you
were talking about a couple weeks ago
the explanation for this DNA is that
there were
apparently two mechanisms for generating
the contents the active contents of
these vaccines the MRNA
transcripts the first one was used for
the clinical trials it was not
sufficiently productive to be able to
scale it up to vaccinate billions of
people so a second mechanism for
generating these transcripts was um uh
utilized that involved uh
plasmids in bacteria so in other words
they involved DNA in the production of
these mRNA transcripts and they did not
purify the stuff out the stuff is there
in huge quantities what did they do they
broke it up they used restriction
enzymes to break up these DNA fragments
so what you effectively have is a chaos
of different length pieces of DNA that
do appear to be integrating into the
nuclear genome now this
this is a disaster because there's all
sorts of stuff in there like um a great
set of evolutionary opportunities for
that DNA potentially it's at the very
least um like broadcasting a powerful
mutagenic signal arbitrarily into the
tissues of the body and I would point
out why that phrasing a mut broadcasting
a mutagenic s uh signal into the tissues
of the body let's imagine that the
chopping up of this DNA effectively
produces a random distribution of
lengths or you know a bell curve you're
going to have some intermediate and then
you know some very long fragments some
very short fragments okay but some
chaotic assortment and then those things
are going to integrate based on
idiosyncrasies of the nuclear genome
what has an affinity for a particular
piece that causes that piece to stick
there and then insert
itself now the problem here is that that
you are introducing stuff stuff that is
not um biologically inert inherently
some of these fragments are going to be
so short that they can't really encode
anything important the most they can do
is disrupt something important which can
be catastrophic but some other things
like uh there's a um Simeon virus 40
promoter that McCaron has found uh that
could actually take stuff that's
supposed to be inactive in the genome
and turn it on now the question is what
might this for example have to do this
whole story is so crazy the turbo
cancers remember turbo cancers how
people were reporting oh my God you're
seeing people who have been in remission
for a long period of time who suddenly
have rapid growth of their their their
tumor or people who were free from
tumors who suddenly are diagnosed with
them this is a pattern I first learned
about from Ryan Cole pathologist who
noticed this in all of the samples
coming across his desk now remember a
pathologist is a unique kind of doctor
because he's not seeing tons of patients
which limits the number of people he can
see what he's seeing is huge numbers of
samples from all sorts of doctors who
are sending him stuff and saying what is
this so he was in a position to see much
more broadly than other people and he
was bold enough to say what he was
seeing and he was talking about the
cancers he was seeing very very early on
and the reason I raise him specifically
at this moment not only is this
potentially relevant to the integration
of random DNA fragments from these
vaccines but but Ryan Cole is currently
fighting to preserve his license what he
he is literally um facing a uh I don't
know what the right term is tribunal but
a yeah a tribunal evaluating whether or
not he can continue to practice medicine
which is absurd Ryan Cole has been ahead
again and again and again on this topic
and he's being punished for it and this
is happening right here in the west
right yeah that's that's that's
terrifying um what do we know about what
can conditions are necessary and
sufficient uh if if we know that much um
four um chopped up pieces of DNA that
are floating about uh to integrate with
your own I don't think uh let's put it
this way I'm no expert my guess is that
because what you have is an elaborate
set of Machinery in the cell designed to
do all kinds of things like repair
broken DNA so if you dump a bunch of
broken DNA into the cell the cell is not
expecting it may respond by going into
repair mode and that may end up
integrating things that you wouldn't
want to integrate
so I would say look okay so maybe no
nothing extraordinary is required at all
maybe I think nothing extraordinary is
required why nothing extraordinary is
required is a story others would be
better positioned to explain but let's
just put it this way it is reckless to
be dumping a chaotic assortment of DNA
fragments into uh a human being
because you know it's a welcome to
complex systems moment what's going to
happen if you do that well the answer is
almost anything can happen but high on
the list of things you would expect
would be uh cancers why well this goes
back to my work actually the idea that
we are riddled with what I called protot
tumors which are wouldbe tumors that
have been arrested as as they've run out
of the capacity to duplicate
those are tumors except that they don't
have toras turned on you know could
random fragments introduced into the
genome activate toras in for which every
cell in your body has the code right it
could so I don't know how all these
things fit together but it's like of all
the Reckless things you could do dumping
a bunch of random fragments of
information into a uh an information
system like this on which your health
depends couldn't be crazier but the link
to what you were presenting a couple
weeks ago
is they ran the clinical trials with the
vaccines produced under procedure one
all right and then they switch to
procedure two to scale it up thereby not
providing any information on the actual
Hazard of vaccines produced by technique
2 when they very well could have used
technique 2 for the stuff that they
tested in the clinical trials so the the
the different method
um may very well have and there's no
reason to think it didn't have created a
different product and therefore having
tested product one um but bringing
product two to Market um means that the
product that is on Market has not been
tested yes exactly has not been tested
and this would you know a a witting
Pharma attempting to obscure hazards
from their uh let's face it utterly
crappy uh production mechanism uh that
is utterly riddled with not just the
design defects in the vaccine itself but
the impurities that come from lousy
quality control right of course in order
to hide those things it would do this it
would have some very careful you know
it's like giving the reviewer of uh an
automobile a version that was
specifically tailored to make them happy
rather than reflect what the consumer is
going to see right it's slight of hand
um okay before we go to the second piece
of video I know this has taking a long
time but before we go to the
um I want to highlight one other odd
fact of this award having been given for
this narrow piece of the MRNA vaccine
technology not only does that
effectively admit what Robert Malone has
been saying and what Alexander marinos
validated that he is the inventor of the
MRNA vaccine technology long since uh
out of patent but I I don't think that
this award demonstrates that it admits
it tacitly because what they're trying
to do is validate the vaccines and
they've given the award for a narrow
piece of technology that is an
interpretation I do not think that that
is the only interpretation I I can't
find another one that would make sense
other than they don't want to validate
Malone because Malone has some things to
say about how this technology has been
utilized but anyway we can leave that
aside nonetheless the pseudo iDine
stabilization of these uh vaccines of
the mrnas in these
vaccines is I think the greatest design
defect on a long list of design defects
in these vaccines now um I said that to
Robert Malone the day the award was
given and he said no he thinks the spike
protein the choice of Spike protein is
the greatest design defect but let's
just say that there's a debate to be had
between those the spike protein is
cytotoxic as we were famously fact
checked for pointing out on Darkhorse
but anyway it is cytotoxic it is um but
the MRNA transcript means that it is
produced far longer in the body so I
guess there's a debate to be had about
which of these things is dumber but um
they're both pretty dumb and one of them
just got a Nobel Prize uh so that's a a
fascinating fact right this this Nobel
Prize was literally given for a a design
defect of the vaccines not arguably one
of their uh strengths all right so let's
go to this next piece of
video this is um a podcast from January
2021 so that same moment that nature was
uh describing the many side effects that
the MRNA platform brings right and the
guest on this podcast is Drew Weissman
who just won the Nobel Prize for thisse
at that point was still two and a half
years from winning the Nobel Prize right
um and yeah uh I will say I'm going to
criticize many of the things he says but
let us remember that some of these
criticisms have to be tempered by the
fact that we hadn't yet vaccinated
billions of people and therefore the
amount of information about the actual
consequence of that was much less how so
how can we be sure that this vaccine
will not cause long-term negative impact
in humans like that's one of our big
questions that we hear a lot so I the
the first to understand what the vaccine
is that the MRNA in the vaccine is
identical to the RNA in your
cells so the RNA in your cells isn't
causing long-term Adverse Events so the
RNA in the vaccine won't either the RNA
is degraded probably within a week it's
completely
gone the lipid nanop particles contain
four types of fat two of the fat FS are
identical to what's in our cells they're
they're
physiologic the other two are present at
incredibly low levels they are gone
within 24 to 48 hours they're just you
the body degrades them they're gone so
nothing of the vaccine is left after
days to a week or
so the question that comes well then how
do you get a long-term adverse event
well you can't from any components of
the vaccine because they're gone the the
MRNA does not integrate into the DNA it
doesn't affect the DNA it
doesn't all right so there are a number
of things to point out here um the
biggest error that he makes he makes
right up front he says that the MRNA is
identical to the MRNA in your cells and
from this he deres IES a tremendous
amount of comfort his point is
essentially look this is in you already
how could introducing a little more of
it possibly hurt you and this is the
biggest piece of garbage one can imagine
for one thing this is the guy whose
invention is making this a very
unnatural thing for which there is no
natural analog in your body so put aside
what his actual invention was for a
moment which makes what he said just
patently not true and he knows
it even if it were
true mRNA is built of certain things and
even if the MRNA that was in his
invention was built of exactly the same
things which it de facto cannot be
because the whole point is that he's
using something new but even if it were
the fact that it uses the same
materials but has instructions to to
make a particular protein is the point
so the idea you know we don't have in us
the instruction set to produce the spike
protein we don't you and I don't many
people do now right if they if they
receive these vaccines so um the you
know the grotesque obvious error there
is no but dude you literally did the
thing that changes the MRNA such that
it's less transient such that it's more
stable such that it stays uh in the body
for longer and that's not what we have
in our bodies already but even if that
weren't true the whole point is that it
is an instruction set it's a factory for
creating something in particular which
in this case they chose the spike
protein oopsy right so this is um crazy
at three levels three okay yeah the
first level is the MRNA itself isn't
like a natural M mRNA because you
altered it dude right so that's one two
is that it is is
informationally novel and it is
therefore causing your body to produce
something that is not naturally in it
and so the thing that is produced could
be good could be bad but it ain't just
your stuff so the whole argument that
you're doing this anyway this won't this
doesn't change anything is like an
argument designed to fool people who
don't know anything and then the third
thing so we've got the modification you
made makes the MRNA itself not natural
um and it's it's not the only way it's
not natural either by the way this
mRNA was codon optimized for the human
environment it has had modifications to
uh the spike protein sequence for
various functional reasons but the point
is it it this just is not natural the
informational content produces something
which could be a toxin it could be a
substitute for some that you should be
producing but don't but but the point is
the saying that you know that thing is
not dangerous because it's made of the
same materials in your toaster yes but
it's a firearm right yeah but it's made
of the same stuff in your toaster you're
not arguing that you know toasters are
deadly are you right so it's like that
kind of argument because that's one and
two yeah and then the third one
is if you produce a protein that you
were not producing early in your
development it is a signal to your
immune system to attack your cells it
tells your immune system that your cells
have been infected by a virus and the
correct response to that is to destroy
your own tissue so not even if the
protein itself that was encoded by the
MRNA was itself inert the fact that it
is novel to your body means that it will
trigger your body to do damage to itself
so that's three different ways this is
nonsense well the trigger your body to
do damage to itself is the same trick as
in traditional vaccines right the uh I'm
I'm going to introduce an antigen that
can hopefully get your immune system's
attention quickly and efficiently and
cause it to recognize kill and remember
so you know that that is the basis on
which traditional vaccines function well
yes and no there are various traditional
vaccines there's one traditional
platform and it's actually the one that
I would say is the the safest that uses
this trick but in a very different way
yes an attenuated virus does cause some
of your tissues to produce a foreign
protein that will get them attacked but
and I believe this point this is this is
a point that I believe has only been
made here on Darkhorse the lipid
nanoparticle
encoding an mRNA message is effectively
a pseudo virus an actual virus that has
been attenuated
has an ecology it has a mechanism of
action that will inherently limit what
tissues it invades yes the next thing
that this guy this now no Bell laurat
goes on to talk about is the fats that
are used to get this into tissues and
the key thing to understand you probably
all learned in high school like
dissolves like fats like fats fats
dislike water they like fat they've
coated this mRNA in fat yourell cells
are coated in fat this is a mechanism of
distribution that has no targeting
whatsoever that means it will by by
Design explicitly right so so as to
protect uh the MRNA in the intercellular
space from the
mrnes um long enough for it to get into
cells well it's not just to protect it
and in fact it probably doesn't even
need protection because it's so pseudo
iDine stabilized that the MRNA Aces
aren't going to take it apart but the
idea is just as soap bubbles join soap
bubbles are made of the same stuff when
they touch each other they join and they
can become two soap bubbles can become
one big soap bubble so that's how cell
membranes work too and this is like a
pseudo membrane the the limpid nanop
particle is functioning like a
pseudomembrane and it bumps up against a
cell and then it spills its contents
into the cell but the point is it
doesn't choose what cell it's going into
unlike any virus so to the extent ENT
that you might make the argument that
this is doing the same thing as an
attenuated virus vaccine the attenuated
virus vaccine is inherently
self-limiting in terms of what tissues
it will just note that you we have we
were talking
about one two and three ways um that um
that this is not just you know just like
taking stuff in that's identical to
what's in your body and your third item
on that list I was saying um sounds very
much like um what traditional vaccines
do but um the the rejoiner that you make
is the critical one and yes we have
talked about that here before which is
that an attenuated virus vaccine um
actually has an organism or a virus um
that exists in nature and that has some
experience with you as a host not you an
individual but you the species if it
didn't then you would not be getting
vaccinated against this thing um and so
it will go after particular tissues not
be indiscriminate whereas a nanolipid
covered piece of mRNA is has no
evolutionary history in a human host at
all and therefore will be indiscriminate
in what cells it attaches itself to yes
and the other traditional kind of
vaccine that is now used where fragments
of a pathogen are introduced in order to
induce an immune response that doesn't
enter cells at all and so that is that
is not causing your immune system to
Target your own cells it doesn't do this
in any way so
in any case what he's what he's saying
is pure nonsense at multiple levels this
is not a natural thing that you should
feel like oh I'm really you
know it's a little bit like saying
GMOs uh we've been genetically modifying
organisms for a thousand years so relax
right for thousands of years so relax
and the answer is no actually you've
genetically modified that organism so
you can dump a bunch of pesticide on it
how good is that pesticide for me right
should I be worried about GMOs yes I
should be for multiple reasons including
that one um but selective reading right
not the same thing right it's slight of
hand it's logical slight of hand
designed to fool people who don't know a
lot um and not knowing a lot isn't the
fault of anybody it just you didn't
study this thing enough to spot their
lies but um but those of us who did uh
this is a really weird thing for
somebody who just got a Nobel Prize to
be saying about their own invention
because he's got to know it's wrong um
but again this is him talking two and a
half years ago uh true but he sure as
hell knew yes uh that this wasn't just
mRNA like the stuff floating around in
your body because he's the world's
expert in modifying mRNA to stabilize it
and put it into people's bodies right I
mean come on okay so just a couple more
points he says that this is degraded
within uh a couple days or at most a
week well let's put it this way if that
was comforting in 2021 if he really
believe that in 2021 then he ought to be
alarmed in 2023 because we now know it
does doesn't limit itself that it's
there for months so why is he not now
sounding the if that was comforting then
he ought to be alarmed now and he
doesn't appear to be he then says well
there are four types of fats and two of
them are natural so don't worry well I
would love in the in the nanolipid in
the lipid nanop particles yeah and then
he says the two that aren't natural um
they're there at very low levels uh what
does very low levels mean is this the
same very low levels of the uh
assurances that the Mercury and the
vaccine that you want me to inject into
my kid isn't problem is it that kind of
low levels right like what does low
levels even mean and then he says and
it's gone within 24 to 48 hours because
the body degrades it now wait a second
are you telling me that you've just
introduced a novel lipid that doesn't
exist in my body but my body is expert
at disassembling it I want to check that
it's maybe that's true but that is not a
slam dunk and the fact that you can't
find it doesn't mean it isn't there
especially if you're not looking very
hard
um so he says nothing of the vaccine is
left uh after days or a week which again
if that was comforting in 2021 it ought
to be alarming now and he says the MRNA
does not integrate into the DNA which
again might be true but he says it does
nothing to the DNA again maybe that was
believed then but we now know that
there's lots of DNA contaminating these
vaccines that it is getting into people
and it appears to be integrating into
their nuclear genome well that's that's
that's a different response though if so
I'm seeing your notes rather than
remembering what he said y um that these
mRNA like the MRNA vaccine does nothing
to the
DNA um is not a response to um these
mRNA vaccines are contaminated with
DNA I agree but again I'm not arguing
that from his perspective in 2021 that
he necessarily knew how these things
were going to be produced or that there
was going to be contamination maybe he
did given what he's willing to say about
the naturalness of the mrnas which he
knows aren't natural I wouldn't put it
past him but even if he was naive then
we should be seeing a different thing
unfold now we should not be seeing a
Nobel Prize be awarded by people who say
that there isn't an adverse event signal
really this is just pure theater you've
got the most prestigious prize in the
world being awarded by by people who
can't even avoid saying obviously wrong
things in a press conference they can't
you know there's not enough vagueness in
the world for them to avoid absolute
lies in their press conference that's
stunning they would give a prize that
can't be
defended um without having to lie oh
okay well I guess that's where we are
but but the final thing I will say is
that I
believe
we knew that the Nobel process was
corrupt many people have in the
aftermath of this pointed out uh Obama's
Peace Prize which is ironic was given to
him before he had the chance to do such
terrible things and then history
reflects very poorly on that choice um
this is not the only place these these
prizes uh are uh really uh quite a
political
phenomenon um but the degree to which
Pharma capture and whatever Travels With
It has obviously completely uh owned
this process and is now delivering um
prizes for design defects in products
that it wishes to expand the market for
that's pretty amazing and what I what
dawned on me in reflecting on this was
we are now living in an
era in which it is literally true that
anything plugged into a major instit
intution is compromised anything
scientific that is plugged into a major
institution is compromised which does
not mean that there is no science
there's lots of science but the only
science that is in any way trustworthy
is ragtag fugitive science right you've
got people who still know how to do
science existing outside of the
institutions right you've got uh you
know a band of rebels who insist on
still doing the job even though
um Pharma and its cronies have attempted
to stamp it out everywhere that it's
supposed to be done that's a strange era
to be living in but at least if you
start with that premise you will not be
so confused by all of the garbage that
is emerging from all of the places that
at one time might have been trusted to
tell you what was going
on yeah yeah that's not very helpful no
but thank you for not saying it's worse
than that because that was pretty bad I
mean I I am relatively certain it is
worse than that yeah but I mean it's
definitely worse than that I just I just
didn't have anything to follow it up
with directly although I have I have a
story to
tell
uh which is about as bad as that it it
is it is the same kind of thing it's the
same kind of
corruption
so in Natural Selections this week uh
where I write on my substack um I wrote
a piece called fish fishy and fish
adjacent uh why eat like an Inuit when
you can pop a
pill and the story is is this I
encourage you to go read it um but
basically in
1913 uh some researchers on the
northwest coast of
Greenland uh described the what were
known then as Eskimos and we now call
Inuit people there as the most
exquisitely carnivorous people on Earth
which I love as a phrase um and
specifically
they found that these people eat almost
entirely the meat of whales seals
seabirds and fish and specifically among
the fish halet capelin uh I don't even
know if I'm pronouncing that correctly
because I've never heard of it and
salmon okay so um exquisitely
carnivorous and whales seals seabirds
and fish uh half a century later in
1971 we had researchers going to the
same place and looking at markers of
disease and found that these same people
have far less heart disease far less
cardiovascular disease uh than do uh for
instance modern uh Danes and other
Northern Europeans um and no diabetes at
all and this in modern times I feel like
in 1971 is kind of modern but also a
long time ago um might well have caused
Collective hand ringing at how horrible
it was was that people with such an
appalling diet right uh could have
possibly ended up being so healthy um
but and yes I I just there is a part of
me that cannot get over um I mean you
and I live around a lot of
seabirds and I must say I admire anybody
who can eat seabird I me I love seabirds
I love like cor oh man I watch them all
day but they do not look delicious those
oil
glands um yeah so and I and I think
basically the the upshot of This
research from 1971 was ah it's the fish
and I and I really I don't know I'm
curious as to why it was that they
decided on it's the fish when it's
whales seal seabirds and fish and I
think probably it's because they know
that as weird O's right those of us who
live in the western educated
industrialized Rich Democratic World um
would be either incapable of or
unwilling to eat whales SEALS or
seabirds um and because fish is already
part of many of our diets especially
halet and salmon like Ah that's the
ticket let's go there it's definitely
the shallow end of the pool with respect
to the Inuit diet exactly so okay
everybody eat more fish eat more fatty
fish in particular cold water fatty fish
and everyone who's alive now has been um
you know has seen what happened
Downstream of that which very quickly um
we get um we get fish oil as the
supplement that is pulled out of fish um
by I think just rigging them but at both
ends and um well I don't know how
they're getting it's a pretty gross
process I'm sure it's I'm sure it's
gross yes um so fish is understood you
know so you know trigger the reduction
of science machine right uh and so very
quickly we get um okay there's two
primary omega-3 fatty acids that fish
have and um asterisk here apparently
there's a lot of suspicious work over in
oh Omega-3s are actually awesome for you
land but um we're going to put that
aside for the moment um and the short
the the three-letter um abbreviations
for these these ex found an externally
high amount in fatty fish um fatty acids
are DHA and EPA and you know suddenly
not suddenly but you know by you know
Fast Forward by another 50 years and
fish oil supplements are one of by far
the most common supplements that at
least Americans take and I I think
that's true in all of the weird
world but oh wait fish oil doesn't turn
out to be living up to the hype uh it
turn turns out you know there's a look
at look at uh mainstream media from even
5 years ago but 10 years ago 20 years
ago and it's pushing you know the heart
healthy effects of fish oil um the
reduction in things like um in
inflammation
specifically um but but then it turns
out maybe not so much maybe we should
have just kept on eating the fish or
maybe we should have been eating the
whales like you know it's you know it's
it's hard to do the analysis with the
reductionist lens it's especially hard
if you're a poor enterprising farmer a
firm who just wants to make a
buck and in that case um if you've
created a drug as amaran Corp has um the
drug Vespa um and I maybe mispronouncing
it but I really don't care if I am um
Vespa is the only product that amaran
cour makes it's an Ireland based Pharm
far
firm and um the single active ingredient
in vesa is a slightly modified version
of one of those two omega-3 fatty acids
found predominantly in fatty fish so EPA
is the non-modified one they've got
something called IP it's just lab
tweaked a little bit which presumably
makes it patentable and boom Off to the
Races for them but what are they going
to do now fish oil is now getting a bad
wrap and it's not that people are
thinking that it's dangerous necessarily
except again asterisk the omega-3 fatty
acid um stuff going on over here but um
really what people are realizing is ah
the research on fish oil supplements
specifically does not seem to have the
promise um of people who just pop fish
oil supplements all the time are going
to be healthy like an in it um they
don't seem to be and um we aren't
getting seabird supplements or whale
supplements or seal supplements so you
know maybe it's time to go back and eat
the actual fish or just in general you
know eat a eat a diet that is is full of
actual whole real food instead of
popping pills to solve your health
problems but uh amaran maker of esba has
a problem because they've got one and
only one product and it has one and only
one active ingredient and that one and
only one active ingredient is a slightly
tweaked modification of a of a omega-3
fatty acid that is predominantly found
in fatty uh fatty fish um so what what
are they going to do they need to keep
on convincing people to take their drug
and um and not fish oil because when
people take fish oil oil they don't win
and they also need to somehow separate
themselves from fish oil because people
are cottoning to the fact that fish oil
isn't actually as effective as we've
been told even though what what their
drug has is well presumably lots of
inactive ingredients God knows what's in
those um but also a single active
ingredient that is half of what is
considered um the useful active
ingredients in fish oil um and it's even
tweaked a little bit so who knows what
that does okay so um in response they
have on their website and you can put up
my screen here this is on the Vespa
website um vesa again being the only
product of the Amar incorporation a
closer look at fish oil supplements when
it comes to protecting your heart learn
how fish oil supplements are different
from
Vasa uh let's go to the right first um
vaspa has proven cardiovascular benefit
in the landmark reduc it trial it's made
up of one active ingredient an
Innovative form of EPA FDA approved and
recognized by medical societies
all right fish oil supplements by
comparison um the FDA found that fish
oil supplements do not meet the stering
required for significant significant for
significant scientific Health claim they
contain lots of stuff and you don't want
lots of stuff do you you want something
simple with just one ingredient um oh
and also fish oil supplements may make
you smell like
fish uh not intended or approved to
treat heart disease I love this one this
is a slight of hand where they're
basically saying fish oil because it's
from fish was not generated as a
medicine therefore you shouldn't use it
as a medicine because if it wasn't
created by us or God or whoever knows
what as a medicine it must not be
useful uh the American Heart Association
advises against and the most expensive
product is one that doesn't treat the
intended condition I don't even know
what that one means I think they found a
fish oil
supplement that has on the label like
this is good for something else entirely
so I don't even know this is a
remarkable thing right this is a
remarkable thing that I find on their
website and it's it's replicated in my
um in my Natural Selections piece fish
fishy and fish adjacent um but I would
like to point out that the entire basis
of their claim are um are are are two I
mean other than the ludicrous right like
don't take fish because or fish oil
because that wasn't made as a medicine
and therefore it couldn't work as a
medicine I don't know how many logical
fallacies are in that claim but they're
a lot right um then they uh appeal to
authority over and over and over again
it's the FDA it's the American Heart
Association it's unnamed medical
societies who really say you should take
our product and not fish oil but then
there's the reduc it trial oh well
there's a clinical trial that shows this
is better than um than than Placebo so
you really should be taking this
clinical trials are the gold standard of
scientific evidence even say the
Platinum standard Brett that's going to
confuse people okay um but the gold
standard for sure yeah no I they are the
gold standard and so I mean really that
ought to be good enough for you um as a
consumer with cardiovascular concerns uh
when deciding whether or not to you know
eat good food and get outside or take
fish oil or take Vasa you probably want
the vesa because the Vasa is the only
one with the positive results of the
clinical trial behind it except oopsy
the placebo that they use with the
control group in their reduc it trial
it's heart toxic it's mineral oil which
is understood to cause heart toxicity
and when this clinical trial was
replicated by a group of researchers who
didn't have perverse incentives because
did I mentioned the reduc it trial was
actually funded by this Corporation I
was going to ask um when a group of
independent researchers independent of
this group of this Corporation did the
trial with an actually neutral
Placebo The Beneficial effects of esba
disappears so the entire reason that
they can Trot out to take their drug is
authority authority authority and a
clinical trial which was um which was
fraudulent and I do want to just read
the last couple of paragraphs in my
piece before we um before we get
to I want to show you a job listing uh
for amaran at the moment as well okay
here we go not that is no science
backing up any of these claims the one
study they have was self-funded and used
to toxic Placebo and every other reason
they Trot out is based on Authority
trust us because the FDA says so trust
us because the American Heart
Association says so trust us because
unspecified medical societies say so
science and medicine are not supposed to
take marching orders from Authority ever
even actually trustworthy authorities in
addition though consider the obvious in
a system where science is being bludgeon
to death and those who are witness to
the crime either yell about it and are
shoved into a corner or remain silent
and continue to collect their paychecks
where the only evidence necessary to
make scientific or medical claims is to
refer to the recommendations of
organizations like the FDA and the AHA
and Publications science and nature in
an era when those same organizations and
Publications are strapped for cash and
looking for new ways to stay
afloat those organizations organizations
and Publications will absolutely get
gamed they will become corrupt they will
get captured and and so they will remain
in existence sort of still draped in the
aura and gravitas of their former
reputations they may look like the
August sheep of old but they are very
much wolves on the inside and here's the
kicker the real reasons that amaran
would have you use Vespa are these in
2021 Vespa brought in over $550 million
net for amaran in the United States and
ve vesa is the only product that Amarin
makes once you know this The Story
begins to make an e easy smooth and so
very quantifiable kind of
sense
wow yeah it's uh it's the well I don't
know how rare these cases are but
because the company makes one and only
one product and that product is a simple
one comparatively you can just see the
game of Pharma played out um very
clearly yeah right this this company
exists to sell this drug which means
that it has to create evidence that
there's a reason to take it it has to
obscure evidence of any harm it has to
um create the impression that
competitors are not something that you
should be interested in and I I think I
noticed on that uh that beautiful little
comparison chart that the you know they
have the image of a fish compared to the
image of a prescription and a rubber
stamp um that's right something like
that right well and the fish smells too
the fish that's what I was going to
point out is that they just very subtly
suggested that that's not the freshest
fish they're trying to induce disgust
disgust is actually a a a well trodden
uh marketing technique for for those
things that you want to have negative
emotions associated with disgust is
brilliant it disgust isly unfortunately
for all of them at this point that
rubber stamp with the prescription P
that is the thing that most of us are
recoil most of us I hope many of us are
recoiling from that now yeah they also
throw in the term rotting there just to
oh yes yeah because the idea of rotting
fish does not make you want to get any
right as soon so as soon as you've had
somebody who's going through the thought
process of evaluating this and the idea
of rotting shows up right it's like okay
well that is now a little flag that is
going to append that thought every time
I go back to it rotting right so
something from that something occurs to
me in your um describing this many
months ago or more than a year ago we
discussed explicitly something that I
called the game of Pharma and it was a
game about finding a uh patentable
molecule or technique so getting some
intellectual property and then coming up
with something uh to which it is
plausibly a
solution then generating the evidence
that yes it has a good effect on that
thing obscuring the evidence that it
does harm of some kind and then you know
getting it to be you know the great
thing is if it gets declared standard of
care you know that takes a lot of money
but uh you can maybe get it to happen
but anyway the game of Pharma is
something that the rest of us are kind
of unaware is being played out but it's
being played out every day of the year
um and another element of it occurs to
me
MH the word supplements is ringing in my
ear mhm supplements has the connotation
of uh woo or con Artistry the idea that
that what you are doing is you are
adding a little something to your diet
right it has a very different
connotation from medicine and so I
actually now see the game of Pharma
playing out over three different kinds
of properties right there's a general
category Pharma digs the stuff that can
be sold under patent because that's
where the the uh the profit is right so
a medicine is something where there's
intellectual property that allows it to
be uh uh promoted and and a huge profit
to be made supplements are something to
be derided because it's from an
unregulated Woo Woo You Know Word of
Mouth superstition blah blah blah blah
blah those people hang probably hang out
in pyramids right and the way that you
can see that this is actually an
illusion is that medicines effectively
change categories when they're out of
patent right what happens is an out- of
patent drug gets derided you know MC
went after uh ior mechin its own drug
for coid because there was no profit
left in icton so it had no interest in
saying hey actually our drug works great
for this so anyway the point is the fact
that drugs which are the darling of
Pharma become a paria at the point that
you can't uh patent them anymore is um
an indicator of what the game is and the
human mind especially I would argue the
Western mind and maybe very especially
the American mind has this attraction to
the idea that the best thing is the
latest version right there's no doubt
that the latest cell phone is going to
be way more powerful than the top ofthe
line from three years ago because
technology Marches On meaning that
there's more and more power available
right and so there's some sense that the
latest version is the best is that
there's there's some Metric that is more
with progress um but more doesn't
necessarily mean better even on that uh
variable and it certainly doesn't
necessarily mean better across the
right well my point would be W with
respect to technology that has not
matured to some final State um it is not
surprising that um things that emerge
later have more power whether they're
You Know Better Built or anything is
another question but does the newer
laptop tend to have more capacity than
the same version from years ago yes but
what that does is it creates a bias in
the mind towards newer is better that is
exactly not true when it comes to
something like molecules that you are
thinking of taking into your body to do
yourself some sort of physiological good
in fact there's reason to prefer the
older stuff which is a we know a hell of
a lot more about what it does the idea
that somebody's going to tweak a
molecule so that it can patent it and
then introduce it to you and say take
some of this it's like well there's one
thing I can tell you we don't know what
the long-term consequences of that thing
are whereas this other drug that's been
around forever we might know an awful
lot and so the fact that Pharma if
Pharma was really interested in health
it would be really interested in all of
the drugs in the
pharmacopia that have demonstrated
effects that might be repurposed for
other things because frankly that's a
very rational process to expect um but
the fact that what it's really
interested in is the new thing tells you
that this is uh that it is not
interested in health and in fact it's
willing to dispense with health in order
to sell stuff indeed it is um remember
though that vaspa um the uh fish oil
derived the omega3 fatty acid fish oil
derived um drug that amaran makes
brought in 550 $550 million net to the
US in 2021 the latest year for which
they post the numbers on their website
which is where I got that number so
they're making bank and they're hiring
so if after that story you're interested
in the job and you happen to be in the
London area here's a job that they're
hiring for this is their key account
manager job and they've got a few key
account manager jobs open I think there
was also one maybe in Lisbon U so
there's a few uh available this just got
posted I don't know if it has been
filled yet um at Amarin you'll make a
difference they say I just want to read
two paragraphs from this um job
description that Amarin is hiring for
rooll
overview this role offers a unique
opportunity for highly successful cams I
forgot oh that's the key key account
manager this role offers a unique
opportunity for highly successful key
account managers to help to continue to
build the UK organization and launch and
grow a product in cardiovascular disease
that has Blockbuster potential note
nothing said yet
M this role will have full
accountability for the territory
business the key account manager will be
responsible for ensuring an optimal
environment for the market access of
amarin's
product driving through to the
commercial launch and patient pull
through in each account the key account
manager will be responsible for the
design and implementation of the
Strategic key account plans and develop
of relationships with national key
opinion leaders in order to drive
amarin's commercial
agenda they're hiring for a number of
positions right now um one of them might
be R&D although I don't think so most of
them are key account
managers this is
entirely about selling it's the game of
Pharma this is the game of farmer that
you were talking about right here this
is the job description literally the job
description for the company that I just
described which is trying to convince
you to take their product which in this
particular case unless they tweaked that
omega-3 fatty acid in a particularly
egregious way in this particular case I
doubt that their drug is less safe uh
than taking fish oil
supplements it's probably not as
effective but you're probably not going
to end up killing yourself with their
drug unlike a lot of the stuff that they
have on the market not these guys
because they just got the one drug but
$550 million to the US net alone in
2021 for a drug with that Bol and
unimpress of a description well of
course they're going to be putting their
money into key account managers they
don't need R&D they've tweaked the one
omega-3 fatty ass that they've got a
tweak that's all they need to do there's
no R&D necessary they've literally got
one product they've got one product
they've got sounds like one study which
they did themselves which suggests
something I mean it was it was published
in a peer-review journal Brett oh
goodness that that does make it good um
but anyway the the idea and the
description that this drug has
Blockbuster potential there's nothing
here to suggest that this has massive
capacity to improve no but the FDA no
it's it's this one um everything is
about this drug um but the FDA panel um
that uh or the advisory panel that then
uh took this the FDA did vote 16 to zero
to approve so so I mean we we must be in
good hands this this is this is what I'm
saying the idea that a drug you know we
already know the dimensions right this
drug might do nothing or very little um
but it still has Blockbuster Blockbuster
potential because the potential is real
ized if you get it declared for example
standard of care exactly so that the I
guess the point is supply and demand is
very different in the context of
medicine because where does the demand
come from the demand comes from the the
person in the white lab coat with the
stethoscope over their shoulders looking
at your chart and soberly saying I think
we're going to put you on
some yeah right um and that process is
where hundreds of millions of dollars
flow from irrespective of the
consequence of the thing in the capsule
yeah
so yeah it's uh it's a lovely example of
what we have all too painfully been able
to infer must be going on uh in Pharma
and the places where it's dispensed and
supposedly
regulated um is stunning all right well
I think that brings us two things one it
is Martin Neil not Martin mcneel I'm
really sorry Martin um that's a terrible
error and I don't know where mcneel came
from in my head um but anyway I want to
make sure that that is uh properly
corrected that was one thing well the
other thing it's probably out of place
here but I did want to point Kevin
mckernin had the ultimate
tweet uh with respect to this Nobel
issue and uh he declared it a Nobel lie
which I thought was so good that uh we
should uh we should call attention to
his his uh beautiful formulation
excellent all right uh so we're gonna
come back with a Q&A in a few minutes uh
we're gonna we're going to stop this
here after uh after talking a little bit
about some other places you can find us
um but then we'll be back uh with our
live Q&A in about 15 minutes and we'll
start that with a question from our
Discord server as we do we have q&as uh
but you can also ask questions uh after
that at darkh hor
submission.com okay uh if you are at the
watch party on locals congratulations
hope you're having fun and if you're not
and you want to join us on locals please
do uh we also have um uh amas there and
our priv private monthly Q&A and lots of
good stuff it's a really great Community
that's growing it's only a couple months
old um but it is growing and we're
excited to see that happen please um
check out fish fishy and fish adjacent
at Natural Selections this week we link
to that um particular piece uh in the
show notes and uh I I encourage free
subscriptions um where you can get stuff
to your inbox every many Tuesdays and
paying subscribers get um more pieces
and um and and more perks we have again
this new store it's Darkhorse store.org
is that right Zach did I get it right
Darkhorse store.org where you can um
purchase many things including evidence
that you have been eating Jake's micro
Pizza
and you want to say anything else about
Jake's micro Pizza are we we good uh it
is hypoallergenic so those of you who um
have sensitivities needn't worry yeah
and nothing on it grows on
trees except the uh we have not yet
deployed the lemon pizza but when we do
then there will be a certain amount of
growing on trees yeah still humanely
harvested though of course always
um let's see what else um
yeah you actually continue to have great
conversations on your patreon as well uh
a couple times a month and actually
those are coming up this weekend I
believe so that would make sense yeah uh
so that is uh that is happening soon you
can you can join Brett there um check
out our amazing sponsors this week which
once again are seed uncruise and what
did you do with your mind Blom mind
Bloom thank you uh and we will have
links to that in the show notes we
supported by you we thank you for tuning
in for talking amongst yourselves for
sharing for liking all of that uh please
join us on Rumble and please join us on
locals and uh until we see you next time
be good to the ones you love eat good
food and get outside be well
[Music]
everyone